نقلت وكاله هو اسرشيتا برس عن متحدثه باسم
الامم المتحده انه لا يمكنه للامين العام
انطونيو جوتيريش ان يتوسط بشاني اوكرانيا
الا اذا ارادت جميع الاطراف ذلك وكان وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيين ديمتري كوليبا قد قل
في مقابله مع الوكاله في وقت سابق ان
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تهدف العقد قمه سلام
بحلول نهايه شهر شباط فبراير المقبل واضاف
انه يفضل ان تكون القمه في الامم المتحده
وان يؤدي الامين العام انطونيو جوترش
الدوره الوسيط
ويا ايمينج
نتجه الى نهايه فبراير عندما تدخل الحرب
عامها الثاني او يتوقع ان تدخل عامها
الثاني من اهداف وصفه السلام هذه عدم
السماح لروسيا بالتلاعب بموضوع السلام
لانها تقول باستمرار انها مستعده
للمفاوضات وهذا ليس حقيقيا لان كل ما
تفعله في ارض المعركه يثبت العكس انهم لا
يرغبون في السلام ونعتقدوا ان افضل من
يستضيف القمته هو منظمه الامم المتحده لان
الامر لا يتعلق باسماء خدمه لبلد ما الامر
يتعلق بالاشراك الجميع وليس هناك افضل من
الامم المتحده لتحقيق ذلك
في المقابل رفض الكريم لان امكانيه اجراء
مفاوضات في الامم المتحده بشروطه اوكرانيا
واقل المتحدث باسم الكريم لندمتري ديسكو
بلاده لا تتبع شروط الاخرين في التفاوض
ابدا واشدد على ان مرجعيه روسيا هي
اهدافها الخاصه والمنطق السليم على حد
تعبيره